all right as soon as i get these tables
set up on the lawn y'all can start
bringing that stuff out
you think you're gonna get ten bucks for
this piece of junk hey
that piece of junk is a wedding gift
from my cheap ass cousin betty
and i was gonna leave a little room to
haggle what the haggle
negotiating you start high they offer
lists
and you meet somewhere in the middle
leaves them feeling like you know they
got a deal
did they not if you did it right how
much are we getting paid today
you're not getting paid squat you're
helping out your mean mall that doesn't
seem fair
yeah we should get something fine
how much you want five dollars each each
that's pretty steep how about i give you
a buck a piece
let's meet in the middle three dollars
each now
we're haggling let me ask you a question
if you break something today are you
prepared to cover the cost of that
no um well we're gonna have to factor
that in
and did you bring your own lunch you
said we were getting pizza
well i did but pizza ain't free and i'm
teaching about negotiating which is a
pretty valuable life lesson right yeah i
guess so
so if my math is right you owe me
two dollars each we owe you
the numbers don't lie dang it
all right listen i love you and your
family
so if you do it for nothing we'll call
it even
take it take it take it you got yourself
a deal
y'all drive a hard bargain i started
bringing that crap outside
i like it it likes you how much
five dollars i only have 50 cents that's
okay
we're haggling i don't know what that
means you make me an offer
and we meet in the middle the middle
what
i'm not really sure
what are you doing considering buying
this jacket
i found chewing tobacco and juicy fruit
in the pocket
does that come with it or is it extra
actually that's not for sale why don't
you look for something else
you sure there's a price tag on it just
take it off
is this some kind of bargaining
technique because i should warn you
i've been to the bazaars in istanbul
where the negotiations are fast
furious and bilingual just take it off
damn it
what just happened that's my dad's
jacket
oh still don't know what happened
okay 10 cents a week for a whole year i
get the raccoon
and to tell people you're my girlfriend
15 cents a week and if you say hello to
me in school i'll say hello back
[Music]
deal
i want to